entreprendre un défi difficile à relever
pour les étudiants le encore plus pour
les étudiantes
aujourd'hui seulement 30 % des créateurs
d'entreprise sont des femmes alors pour
pallier ce déficit lui vs qu organise
aujourd'hui sa journée annuelle
entrepreneuriat étudiant sous un angle
bien particulier l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin pour les aider à se lancer ici à
l'université on organise un certain
nombre donc d'ateliers sûr sûr sûr cette
journée pour notamment lever l'ensemble
des difficultés liées à la
méconnaissance du métier d'entreprise
monter une entreprise
il ya beaucoup de législation il ya il
faut savoir aussi monter son business
plan il faut savoir rencontrer c'est pas
remonter ses nouveaux contrats
rencontrer ses futurs acheteurs
il ya tout un aspect réseau et c'est là
dessus qu'on essaie de les aider donc
ici à beaucoup d'entrepreneurs en
activité qui sont là pour créer des
liens créer des réseaux potentiel et en
particulier en nombre d'entrepreneurs
féminine avocate coach sportive ou
encore graphistes les entrepreneurs
féminine représente tous les domaines
d'activité sophie travaille dans la
finance elle s'est mise à son compte il
y a huit ans et aujourd'hui elle veut
montrer l'exemple
il faut oser c'est pour ça que je suis
là aujourd'hui pour dire aux
entrepreneurs à ceux qui ont envie de se
lancer et surtout à celles qui ont envie
de se lancer qu'il faut y aller qui font
usées
que effectivement créer son entreprise
c'est pas facile qui a plein d'embûches
mais il ya aussi plein de systèmes pour
aider il ya des structures qui
accompagnent la création d'entreprise ya
des coachs qui accompagne aussi cette
année 80 projets étudiants participent à
des concours de pitch où l'on teste les
idées de création d'entreprise sophie
échanges avec ce groupe d'étudiants en
l3 et en profite pour donner quelques
conseils et trois minutes ça fait quoi
ça fait super court il faut s'entraîner
avec un timer parce que sinon on a à
peine commencé la phrase non dans la
catégorie jeune pousse donc je crois
qu'il ya six groupes et c'est juste un
petit pitch des 32 trains minutes pour
présenter un projet trois minutes pour
convaincre et de nombreux prix a
remporté cette année le prix de
l'entrepreneuriat féminin devrait
encourager les créatrices de demain